a cidade
artefatos mais poderosos da história da
história da cultura das mais fascinantes
realizações humanas onde conexões
valoriza o espírito criativo onde se
viabilizam destinos individuais e
coletivos e dentro da qual transformamos
a paisagem transformamos o tempo criamos
o seu sentido de futuro
quando falamos em arqueologia da cidade
não pensamos apenas aqueles fenômenos
muito antigos recuperados pela ação
nossa daquela longos mas no conhecimento
dos fundamentos o conhecimento genético
de um fenômeno que se propaga ao longo
dos séculos
portanto também na descoberta de
elementos constitutivos que animam a
inteligência criativa panificadora
realizadora em qualquer época em
circunstância essa imagem que vemos é de
um projeto hoje
vanguarda da pesquisa tecnológica
prospecções em fotografia aérea usando
satélites aeronaves jones e sem
interferir no estado da território
muitas vezes territórios difícil a
certos descobre como a reta as linhas
ordenadores da cultura transforma o
território criando vias muralhas
habitações a otimização dos recursos
hídricos e naturais em geral e ao
conhecimento desses elementos
transformadores na cidade mostra
comportamentos que se reproduzem
inclusive na circunstância atual e
também nos mostra a longa escala durate
viva desse fenômeno
sabemos que a cidade é também a nave em
que nós atravessamos muitos séculos
dezenas de séculos navio em que
evidentemente nos conduza destinos muito
variados não apenas espaciais mas
sobretudo aqueles que dão sentido à
existente aqui vemos exatamente nesse
sentido com a paisagem transformada cria
uma cicatriz do mundo essa cicatriz é
uma marca da nossa passagem
nesse território as fotografias aéreas
exploram o território do oriente médio
onde surgiu o fenômeno urbanístico com
milhares de anos atrás
nessa pesquisa sobre a origem da cidade
recebeu uma um aporte revolucionário no
fim dos anos 50 e início dos anos 60
quando foi descoberto na anatólia
há hoje porque ama a cidade de shaltalo
rio khan parte de um conjunto de
pequenos vilarejos que floresceram muito
muito antes das cidades do egito da
mesopotâmia a partir de nove mil antes
de cristo
essa tal rio cuca que tenta encerrar da
revelou um complexo de habitações sem
praças ruas e templos sem grande energia
social mas com espaço de convívio
compartilhado que perdurou por 4.500
anos aproximadamente
o avanço da pesquisa revelou
conhecimento extraordinário sobre essa
sucessão histórica e o ot di'anno à vida
privada à vida comunitária que a cultura
material revela como nessa parede de uma
residência onde foi encontrado também
não apenas a cidade mais antiga mas
também a representação da cidade
mas a antiga de que se tem notícia ela
está estampada na cadeia na parede de
estuque da residência na qual a incisões
de pontos um sentido tracejado ortogonal
para facilitar a visualização a uma
transposição gráfica que mostra o
fenômeno urbanístico aglutinado junto
uma montanha de fato no passado um
vulcão o carro razão andar junto ao qual
estava a cidade chega ao rio com as suas
habitações
o descoberta arqueológica revelou que o
espaço representada naquela parede era o
espaço vivido ali percebido uma visão
aérea ano
essa visão de alguém que se alça do
território com imaginação e ciência e
representa esse espaço especulando
imaginando produzindo uma identidade a
especulativa
nas imagens essa uma das mais de 20
plantas de ocupação de seu território
que
preocupado continuadamente para esse
longo período
aqui vemos cada estágio desses
corresponde a uma longa era em torno de
100 a 200 anos de ocupação e reocupação
do mesmo espaço por 4.500 anos para que
tenha uma ideia é mais ou menos o tempo
que nos separa da construção das grandes
pirâmides na quarta dinastia do egito
antigo e ele ouve se alonga continuidade
hoje estudamos que fatores levaram à
exaustão desse modo de vida há por volta
de quatro mil 500 antes de cristo e city
chapel hill portanto precursor e hoje o
objeto de estudos mais relevante da
tecnologia antiga praticado na
atualidade não cite um financiamento
extraordinário de grandes corporações
globais em atividade
esse aqui é o sonho todo na área de
escavações nos diferentes níveis e
aquela pintura que eu mostrei a pouco
está localizada nessa parede
aqui no mundo antigo compareceram também
outras imaginações da cidade concepções
que reinaugurar um espaço uma das mais
importantes veio pela obra de um faraó
revolucionário à renato tonini precursor
de um visionário que para implantar uma
concepção tecnológica e política
inovadora criou uma nova cidade a
retrato horizonte deaton
nela esse disco solar presidia uma noção
cósmica fonte de vida é que está aqui na
turquia sua esposa nefertiti pela
primeira vez na história das da cultura
crianças imperiais representadas no colo
dos pais que sou majestaticamente
contemplou a fonte do que era então um
princípio de ordem princípio de ordem e
se animou também a construção dessa
cidade na 18ª dinastia ou seja a século
14 antes de cristo
aqui está um pouco da visão da planta da
cidade fato notável é que s para ó
também avatar de uma mística muito
valiosa na modernidade desde o século 16
mas um longa história até a atualidade
é o misticismo rosa cruz ea visão de que
há um conhecimento mágico a procedente
dos antigos egípcios o grande autor foi
exatamente esse akhenaton esse
conhecimento
mas a cruz tinha grandes entusiastas no
brasil no início do século 20 um deles o
autor desta jóia da arquitetura e do
urbanismo contemporâneo
a obra de luci costa brasília construída
com inspiração dessa idéia de akhenaton
como se fosse uma grande av
transe histórica criando uma nova era
uma nova utopia essa do planalto central
na planta que ilustra o prémio ganhando
vencido pelos e costa fica mais claro
ainda essa matriz é hora de parada e
conhecida uma conexão entre aquela
ambição de um novo tempo de akhenaton e
daquele que se avizinhava
no cenário de brasília a sav urbanística
não imaginava o autor com a sua ciência
e poesia que também outra ave estenderia
às suas asas sobre esse território
rapinando nação e se valendo da
distância que esse cenário oferece pra
realizar algo de natureza oposta ao topo
e urbanística uma lapidação nacional
comum sofre os brasileiros muito
intensamente nos dias atuais
a ave de rapina que ilustrada outras
imaginações da cidade cresceram junto
com utopias da finalidade da cidade
utopias que dessem um sentido valioso ao
cenário de vida que a cidade
no apogeu da sua experiência experiência
da apólice clássica na grécia 1 o
urbanismo nutrido por muita filosofia
filosofia detalhes pitágoras todos os
sábios que ali a atualizar um
conhecimento muito antigo e
revolucionaram a cultura hipódromo de
mileto desenvolveu o conceito da planta
ortogonal que distribui o espaço em
blocos e equilibrados e simétricos
visando um sentido de equalização das
distâncias das diferenças sociais um
horizonte de a comunicação com
lívio e equilíbrio na cidade e da qda
está a matriz o que se tornou a
principal a concepção urbanística ao
longo dos séculos dessa gênese a
atualidade depreende portanto o modelo
também conhecido como econômico e que
está marcado no território que habitamos
a porto alegre que pode ser toda do
deduzida desse ambiente ortogonal em que
estamos cujos ângulos e vetores em
estrita instinto rigoroso a sentido
ortogonal ângulo de 90° se comunica com
os corredores elevador pré de
quarteirões a comunicação entre espaço
vivido arquitetônico e o cenário
urbanístico
essa mesma pn aqui numa reconstituição
gráfica da escola alemã que a a
recuperou psicologicamente é prestar
atenção nesse cenário porque ele aparece
na tecnologia fascinante desse espaço
esse é o cenário do concelho à boleia da
cidade toda ambiente racional
equilibrado no qual surpreendentemente
nossa habituados a esse corpo cidade
sentimos uma tocante familiaridade
ao entrar na cidade como se redescobrir
somos o mesmo aquário onde somos criados
um mundo onde nos habituamos por uma por
um condicionamento cognitivo cultural a
estabelecer relações disciplinas medidas
proporções a cidade ortogonal antiga
essa concepção foi difundida com a ideia
de cidade antiga que foi a base de
expansão de dois grandes impérios de
alexandre magno e possivelmente romano
impérios de grande expansão urbanística
fundações e reformas de cidade
igualmente a teoria de hipódromos de
elétrons teve seu apogeu em um novo
gênio da arquitetura e urbanismo que foi
mário vitrúvio espólio um arquiteto e
urbanista revolucionário ativo há entre
o final a do mundo antigo último e o
primeiro século de um século antes e
depois de cristo e que sistematizou tudo
que fez de podas e criou uma nova noção
conectando corpo habitação cidade espaço
essa teoria muito conhecida pela imagem
icônica que é a ilustração em que
leonardo da vinci e descreve os
o indivíduo em que a partir das
proporções do corpo humano a dokova do
pé da perna e do núcleo dado pelo umbigo
se deduz o restante do espaço e do
regime de proporções que se dá para
inscrição do círculo quadrado e por todo
o conjunto de relações geométricas que a
partir daí se estabelecem
e essa página em que leonardo tenta
demonstrar o princípio a e podame
conquistar em vitrúvio precisamos
vitruvius homem de virtudes de leonardo
da vinci e essa concepção portanto daqui
convertida também um ícone cultural de
ampla propagação o seu principal evento
arquitetônico sobrevive no centro de
roma é o panteão de agripa exatamente
realiza a inscrição de um desse
princípio de proporção e simetria regido
pela relação entre o círculo e o
quadrado
esse mesmo a fenômeno produziu a o
conjunto de cenários de habitação de
vida no mundo antigo esse é o sítio da
polônia recuperado pela ação das equipes
e arqueológicas que dirigir nessa
escavação por 14 anos e que revelaram na
costa do mediterrâneo oriental israel
uma cidade romana ordenada com todos os
princípios rigorosos completamente
diferente a paisagem é uma
característica dessa racionalidade que
ela se impõe ao território
independentemente das suas variações
é uma espécie de autoritarismo e de
ambição na física da ração dá razão a
este modelo junto com o colapso do mundo
antigo de sua forma de vida
sucedeu o chamado modelo orgânico em
cidades que se aglutinavam sem
planejamento em torno de núcleos de
poder que eram o palácio ea igreja aqui
representados na cidade onde nasceu e
floresceu a obra terá sua maneira um
barco uma ilustração de gravura que
mostra um modelo muito vivido em cidades
européias em outros fenômenos similares
da cidade orgânica que se aglutina a
volta de um núcleo a e que produz a nós
homens vitrue anos que nasceu em porto
alegre
queira ou não é habituado a essa cidade
pedro viana
sentimos um desconforto
provocativo porque não há pontos de
referência que nos dê segurança no
território da cidade
igualmente não há outro tipo de
segurança que a sanitária a propagação
de enfermidades pavorosas é um dos
grandes problemas da cidade que se torna
um fenômeno crítico e é formada quando
exatamente no início do século 15
vitrúvio é redescoberto um dos grandes
feitos do renascimento quando em 1414 os
seus dez livros de arquitetura são
descobertos em um mosteiro em san galã
na suíça um grande sábio renascentista o
debate on line ea partir dali se
redescobre a noção de espaço de
arquitetura se rede fica a cidade com um
modelo a ortogonal as cidades portanto
passa a sofrer mutações com a inclusão
do elemento clássico com o orgânico 1 a
uma cidade em particular onde as
mutações são muito tangíveis muito
conhecidas porque muitos visitam em
algum momento da vida passa a conhecer
paris
na origem da aldeia reformada para uma
ocupação romana que estabeleceu o carlos
um ex-coordenador em torno do qual no
meio no mundo medieval se aglutinou uma
cidade descrita de modo extraordinário
por umberto eco no livro o cemitério de
praga aquela cidade pestilento doentia
de comportamentos conspiratórios essa
cidade que se torna também um problema
quando há uma emergência de de uma crise
social no século 19 a provoca revoltas e
junto com ela a um imperativo de
reformas que são feitas pelo chamado
grande precursor do urbanismo
contemporâneo o barão de hausmann e aqui
está a parede iluminada com as suas vias
que é resultado desse processo a cidade
orgânica contemporânea tem outro cenário
outro sentido ela não é aquela a um
conjunto por celular da cidade medieval
mas motoquinha sustentável como nessa de
função canção a cabo foi um arqueólogo
um arquiteto belga que atualiza com
princípios de sustentabilidade ecologia
a ambição de uma cidade contemporânea
não faltaram utopias do século 20 com
essa de frango white querendo criar uma
cidade
os problemas de transporte visão da
natureza correspondência uma ambição de
futuro cidades pudessem flutuar e se
desvencilhar das prisões e que
constrangem a sobrevivência da cidade um
território sempre com as marcas desse
passado que aglutina ordena cria ícones
também a cidade moderna gerou transtorno
da poluição do da impregnação uma de um
tempo industrial de um tempo em que
predomina caô poluição e um colapso da
expectativa de vida que é exatamente a
cidade de destino a a otimizar com o
cenário de convívio é estádio 1987 a
copa decidido que o icônico do a quem
foge o hemose na própria cidade
industrial
recentemente se reacende o debate sobre
a reconquista da cidade pelo ser humano
com a obra desse protagonista do
urbanismo atual que é o dinamarquês de
ang ao legal
a crítica o fundamento do urbanismo e no
guarda-chuva de suas idéias se renal
grave lesão de uma cidade para pessoas
a obra recente de enorme impacto global
um l com ela se pretende humanizar o
cenário destroçado da cidade do século
20 tomadas por esse espírito devastador
do carro e da obra a de grandes
proporções urbanas e kone disso o que
foi feito na times square onde ocupação
singelo e desonerada do espaço com
reality cadeiras de praias poço coração
de uma das maiores metrópoles do mundo
como cenário de uma revolução de
comportamentos da cidade e aqui estamos
nós de novo nosso território um caso
exemplar a porto alegre igualmente
podame que acabo de assinar lá como
conexão um momento de espaço em que
vivemos nessa porto alegre que se
aglutinam ideia de memórias e que sua
terra e transforma o seu passado no qual
há uma marca genética e irrevogável é um
porto de intensa vitalidade hídrica de
desportos vida econômica vida religiosa
celebra uma identidade identidade que
conteve no passado inclusive um segundo
o epíteto foi a cidade sorriso
onde está o sorriso da cidade que tem
alegria no nome
gostaria também no colapso dessa esse
gozo com o sion o entorno hídrico
perdido nas últimas gerações se trata
agora de portugal em porto alegre
a rede descoberta do sentido humano
também mas também do seu sentido na
paisagem de como esse cenário de
potencialidade de possibilidade pode se
realizar como ambiente estético promotor
de toda a melhor potência da a
realização humana há um inimigo contra
essa potência na cidade moderna
esse inimigo não tem pudor em afirmar a
primazia do carro e da construção
monumental a especulação imobiliária
desenfreada a cobiça de lucro à revelia
o uso dos conceitos e imaginações que
criaram a cidade daquele passado e
memorial que acaba de apresentar aos
sentidos do futuro que serão possíveis
dentro de uma cidade
vejam o quadro hoje cônico escala global
em que há essa realização a cupidez
imobiliária desenfreada a produção a
sombra que frustra a natureza de um
balneário essa camboriu hoje vítima da
desenfreada a estupidez de
incorporadoras
a aem em franco descaso com a natureza
a bela do fenômeno cidade voltamos
portanto um elemento crucial da pole mas
aquele que todos temos nostalgia de
todas as idades ente cento em falta uma
ágora um ponto de encontro das pessoas
circulem troquem idéias discutidas
soluções brindem passam música celebra
em realizem ali o que é crucial umbigo
de vitalidade não apenas para o
indivíduo mas para o cosmos que criamos
um ambiente da cidade pois como disse
tucci diz o historiador grego do século
5o a cidade não são as muralhas são os
cidadãos que estão dentro dela isso
constitui apólice
portanto uma apólice deve se descobrir
com essa inteligência acumulada com essa
imaginação potencializada com esse
sentido de vida
a ação e renovação entre passado
presente e futuro como uma festa que
pode ocorrer no espaço da cidade
obrigado
[Aplausos]